the blue jays are back in buffalo for
the first time this season robbie gets
to start he wasn't as sharp as he has
been going just four and two thirds
inning as his last start that was
against the yankees
once you pitch and there's that slider a
very good one and a strike out one away
but as a pitcher i think you have to be
very aggressive against this team and
stay in the strike zone because they
can't hurt you with the long ball
that's swinging and missing the sliders
so
ray starts out with a couple of
strikeouts two up two down for robbie
ray in the strike zone he's got a little
bit of a hole in the upper parts of the
strike zone with the fastball
[Applause]
got in on his hands pops it up and lana
guerrero is there makes the catch and
foul territory
good inning for robbie ray three up
three down with a couple of strikeouts
top of the order when we come back
marcus simeon
for sandy it's his 12th start of 2021 he
took the loss against the phillies his
last timeout in fact his last two starts
marlin's infield busy
should turn into outs
that one in the air out to center field
but martay is there for out number one
so here's vladimir guerrero jr and we
talked about his great run in
td ballpark in dunedin
he really tore up he had 4 10
during the homestead and he goes after
the first pitch and rips it down the
right field line that's a fair ball off
the wall down in the corner and vladi
guerrero will get into second base with
a slide ahead of the throw
for guerrero that's his 11th double last
year 206 so talk about improvement wow
nearly 100 points better
broken bat roller to short jazz a long
throw
and they get him by his step works
around the double
yeah i agree with you 100
and last year it was kind of an
emergency
renovation because they thought they
were going to play elsewhere
there's a high fastball robbie ray has
three strikeouts against the first four
matters he's faced tonight former blue
jay john birdie this season hitting just
170.
now as far as its second diaz at first
they both singled with two outs
swinging a miss there's another slider
as ray strikes out three in the inning
first and second one out for vladi
guerrero jr laddie doubled his first
time up
goes after the first pitch and hits it
hard left get up ball get out of here
guerrero has seen two pitches tonight
he's got a double and a three-run homer
there is something about this ballpark
that brings the best out of the blue
jays the crowd you can hear the crowd
this is the first time the blue jays
when they hit a home run they're getting
cheering they didn't get it in florida
they're getting it in buffalo and vladi
is such an accomplished hitter the way
that he can come into the game with a
game plan recognize pitches early in the
at-bat and then when he gets that pitch
hit it and hit it with authority
and a called strike three sandy bounces
back with a couple of called strikeouts
but vlad guerrero jr with a three-run
shot
now he's sitting 3-1 count right here
feeling good you know you're going to
get a good pitch to hit it's a three-run
lead 3-0 you know feeling pretty good
marte will
take the walk when everybody's healthy
it's it's a formidable form excuse me
formidable lineup
on cue marte fly ball deep left gorielle
twists and turns and marty is going to
come in and score
luis that is starling is into second
base with an rbi double and it's now 3-1
got twisted and turned around
this ball hit well but not out deep
drive to the warning track in left
really never took his eyes off the
baseball he should have stayed drop step
left and not gone back to the right if
he would have just kept going he would
have been perfect line to make the catch
i'm not sure why he went back and
and the oscars been hot as well heading
over 3 40 in may
first and third one out
simian's at third guerrero's at first
guerrero's running on the pitch and it's
foul no it's a fair ball simeone will
come in to score
laddie goes all the way to third base
another great piece of base running by
the blue chase
so to oscar will pick up an rbi as
simeon comes in to score
two and two
chopper
behind the second base bag martay makes
the play
and the inning is over but the jays get
a run right back
ray has eight strikeouts through five
innings
another good slider and let's strike out
number nine for robbie ray
here's how far of the catcher he has
singled and hit into a double play and
this could be another double play but
the simian back to guerrero and that is
a double play
second double play of the night they
both come off the bat of jorge alfaro
will go to the bottom of the six
florida lottery in-game jackpot for
sandy alcantara lowest barrel rates this
season so what's a barrel trying to
simplify it for you perfect exit velo
and launch angle for an extra base hit
he doesn't give many of those up he's
been very good for the next three days
to get it cleared up
lefty in the bullpen swinging to miss
strike three two outs here in the inning
headline right whaling and bailing and
sailing well that's kind of what you do
when you get sometimes a guy that's
throwing pretty hard and young guys tend
to think that they have to swing as hard
at
98.99 miles an hour
1-2
goes up and gets that one a fly ball out
to left for john bertie who puts it away
sandy threw six
but the jays have a 4-1
lead new picture for the blue jays is
rafael dolis making his 20th appearance
bullpen
here's the one-two pitch cut on and
missed a big strikeout for dolis
that's a good slider right there
quick outs two strikeouts for the lease
coming back with a slider here it's one
and two on aguilar
[Applause]
how about that inning rapio de lis comes
in and strikes out the side
loris has a couple of hits tonight he
had a little bloop in the right field
and had a soft single in the center he's
two for three
three two pitch
high and deep to left field bernie is
back he's looking up this one is gone
long home run for burial
his fifth home run of the season in his
third hit of the night
[Applause]
you know don't forget about guriel
he is as hot as anybody on the blue jays
right now you can just see how patient
he is at the plate
jordan romano comes into the ball game
it is not a save situation but charlie
montoya wants to close out the game
3-1
way outside and the marlins have loaded
the bases with two outs in the ninth
well mattingly will send up another
left-handed bat
it's going to be jose devers
bases are loaded
three and two two out so runners will be
moving on the pitch there they go
swinging a miss he came back with the
slider and strikes him up to end the
ball game
jordan romano strikes out the pinch
hitter and strands the bases loaded in
the ninth in the blue jays win